and welcome back to CBS this morning the
Senate is ready to put a president on
trial for just the third time in US
history you will do impartial justice
according to the Constitution and the
laws so help you God I do Chief Justice
John Roberts who will preside over the
impeachment trial was sworn in yesterday
he then gave the oath to senators who
will decide mr. Trump's fate opening
statements are expected to start Tuesday
there is still no agreement on calling
witnesses to testify the swearing-in
followed a report saying the Trump
administration broke the law by
withholding security aid from Ukraine
that's according to the Government
Accountability Office a nonpartisan
watchdog the administration's delay of
nearly 400 million dollars approved by
Congress is that the center of the
impeachment trial this morning Tony is
with one of the senators who will hear
evidence in the impeachment trial Amy
Klobuchar Thank You Michelle senator
Klobuchar has a big role to play in this
trial as ranking member of the Rules
Committee and she's also a Democratic
presidential candidate and she joins us
now thank you so much Tony thank you for
being here yes and the reason you're
here on the East Coast it's because
yesterday you were in Washington DC and
it looks like you're gonna be in
Washington DC for at least a couple
weeks how is that going to affect Iowa
you're fifth in the polls right now 17
days before right yes but rising okay
granted 17 days before people go to
caucus are you gonna lose momentum by
having to be here for a Senate trial
absolutely not I have a fantastic
operation with people who are incredible
in every major town in Iowa I've got my
husband and daughter out this weekend in
New Hampshire and then on their way to
Iowa and I'm gonna be there for three
days I'm a mom I can do two things at
once you've been staking your campaign
there on your presence I mean sometimes
doing nine events in a given day oh
you're gonna be at a trial that starts
every single day at one six days a week
we're gonna be shuttling back and forth
you know it is my constitutional duty
and when I can go campaign in those
early states including Nevada and South
Carolina I will but when I have to be
there I will and one of the great things
about having these early state
as the voters get to know you and I
think they're going to understand that I
have a constitutional duty to be there
we can Skype in we can phone in we will
have I have more endorsements in the
state of Iowa legislators farmers than
any other candidate in the race
so I have people that are out there
helping me right now and we just picked
up a new endorsements in New Hampshire
including the Deputy Speaker of the
House so let's get one question in on
impeachment then go back to Iowa the big
question is are there gonna be witnesses
do you get a sense as someone who has
worked with Republicans who know
Republicans very well behind the scenes
do you get a sense that there are some
colleagues across the aisle who will
vote for witnesses in this trial yes
they have said it publicly
senator Romney is very clear yeah
senator Romney made it very clear that
he would like to hear from John Bolton
one of the primary witnesses because he
was a gatekeeper for the president's
national security information
I think the GAO report that government
accountability report that Michelle just
mentioned on your program that is really
interesting because that was a
nonpartisan group that said that he had
basically broken the law that's a
nonpartisan agency so you've got that
and every trial we've had in history has
had witnesses Tony I mean you cannot
have a trial without witnesses and right
now we're just asking for four witnesses
who have unique information about the
president holding back aid to a foreign
country so let's jump back to Iowa and
the campaign trail in 2020 your fifth
right now in most polls and among the
people you're trailing are Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders who have
staked out more progressive positions in
the party I was looking at a report just
this morning that said the average
family is or the typical family is
actually poor today than they were back
in 2000 life expectancy in this country
is falling people are not hopeful that
their kids are gonna do better than they
have done there are big problems and yet
you've got this more moderate position
are you out of step with maybe the
progressive vision that is working for
these other candidates well no and what
isn't working right now for so many
families Donald Trump's policies because
you have basically every day he boasts
about how great it is and then you have
so many people where it's still really
hard to afford prescript
and drugs I have been the leader on that
in the Senate or it's hard for them to
send their kids to college I have
different proposals than my colleagues I
think they are more practical yet
progressive and the difference between a
plan and a pipe dream is you can
actually get a plan done I passed over a
hundred bills as a lead Democrat I know
how to do this and I have a record of
winning Oh in suburban and rural areas a
lot of these issues though in America
have developed over Democratic and
Republican administrations and a big one
is wealth inequality and the top one
percent has more than the bottom ninety
percent of the wealth well just three of
them have more than the bottom 50% so
you've been edging up to supporting a
wealth tax to try to fund programs to
help everybody else could you say today
that you support a wealth tax well I've
always said I'm open to that I just want
to make sure you can get it through
legally but there are other things we
can do Tony that are much more concrete
repealing parts of the Republican tax
bill where the president went down
tomorrow Lago and said to his friends
hey you just got a lot richer there were
a lot of people in America that we're
not in that room so heavy so doing that
taking the capital gains rate and
bringing it closer to the personal rate
closing the loopholes for hedge funds
closing the loopholes for oil giveaways
there you literally can get over a
trillion dollars by making concrete
changes so I've showed how I'm gonna pay
for every single thing that I want to do
from helping with K through 12 schools
on and I think that's really important
to have a president someone that doesn't
just have pie-in-the-sky ideas but
actually shows how they're gonna pay for
things so two quick questions - were
running out of time here your ideas are
similar to two Biden and Budaj and yet
you trail them in the polls let's just
take went up to 10 points anew handy New
Hampshire in it four points behind the
vice-president yeah who's counting
though so make the case for yourself
against a Joe Biden who people see has
center ideas and also was moderate Here
I am from the heartland I grew up in
Minnesota
my grandpa worked on the iron ore mines
1500 feet underground saved money in a
coffee can to send my dad to a Community
College from Pennsylvania have that
working-class guy I'm from in the middle
of the country and that is where we need
to
in those states like Wisconsin and
Michigan and Iowa and Ohio and
Pennsylvania so let's start with that I
think I have you look at my record I am
the one that just won 42 Trump counties
in my state 31 counties in Iowa went to
Barack Obama and then Trump I have the
record I actually have the receipts I
like doing that I won in those counties
no one else on that stage people talk
about it but no one else has led a
ticket where they have won repeatedly in
rural and suburban districts and brought
in independence and moderate Republican
want to get one eyebrows in on sexism
after the 2016 campaign I talked to
Hillary Clinton and she told me that her
debate experience with Donald Trump was
imbued with sexism her words she has a
whole file on sexism in politics on the
campaign trail and in this 2020 election
is sexism still a problem for you you
know there is no doubt there can be
double standards about women and
politics about we didn't have that we
would be able to name our favorite woman
president we can't do that because we
haven't had one what do I think I'm
proud to be a woman candidate I would be
so proud to be the first woman in
president but I am running on my merits
and that is a point I have made
repeatedly when I have won really tough
elections against tough opponents I have
done it by making the case that I'm
accountable that I get things done
I have people's back and I don't make
promises I can't keep
so people are tired of the noise and the
nonsense and the extremes they have a
home with me that's how I win senator
Klobuchar thank you very much